the Joe Rogan experience so your mom
your grandmother had your father when
she was 15 years old right whoa yeah
back in the early days of World War two
she apparently was playing around with
her boyfriend she claims to be a virgin
but at that point what something got
somewhere that shouldn't have and she
suppose during high school right so I
was raised by my grandmother she was in
her 40s when I was a kid and she was the
one that taught me to always stay young
keep your you know adults ruin
everything that's probably why I work on
aging adults ruin everything but how was
her advice like in terms of like why how
do you avoid what adults are doing wrong
well you know she she'd grown up during
the Depression and then World War two
and then the Communists came into
Hungary and raped it a lot of people she
had no she had had no respect for
Humanity so by the time I came along
first of all she put all of our energy
into to me and I'm I was a spot bride as
a kid so that that was wasn't helpful to
me I think now as an adult but more
importantly she wanted me to do the best
I could with my life she said David do
what you can to make this world a better
place
make sure that you leave this place
better than you found it and that's what
I'm trying to do wow what a pro founded
piece of advice for a grandchild she was
a rebel she taught me forget the rules
right kind of like you do just I'm going
my own way and we'll see how this goes
she so she went to Australia she said
[ __ ] Europe I'm outta here she went to
Australia the furthest place she could
find from Europe never went back she
went on Bondi Beach in Sydney in a
bikini which was rebellious notice she
got taken off the beach boat by the
police would you have to wear back then
are the full little British thing deep
dandy knees would it down to your knees
I think so did they look like maybe it
was a full one-piece but it allowed to
show your belly that's what I think but
she was a rebel she went to New Guinea
by herself in the 60s what year was this
where she was wearing a bikini that
would be fifth
six you couldn't wear a bikini in the
50s Wow
well okay like those pinup girls right
when you see them they always had
one-piece suits on like it yeah so
imagine you Guinea in the 60s as a woman
on a run up in the highlands she claims
to have eaten human flesh and she spent
most of the time drunk as well did you
see that article that was yesterday
where they were interviewing an
Australian a guy it was a doctor or
scientist who's talking about climate
change and he was saying that we have to
start eating human bodies and that human
bodies are very nutritious and that we
just put them in the ground and it I was
reading it I was like okay is this guy
trolling like what is what is he doing
here is he a completely insane person
but his advice was our dependence on
meat is ruining like in some places
where they're you know they're stripping
the rainforests to make room for cattle
grazing he was saying that we are
getting rid of perfectly good meat every
time we put someone in the ground well
we are but but to suggest that it sounds
insane to me yeah because it was we
throw away half our food anyway at least
in this country it was a mainstream
publication that this guy was talking
about like the last thing you want to
encourage is people getting used to
eating people he's been watching World
War Z maybe yeah I mean it's just one of
those like come on I was I was going is
this guy just trying to get attention
like this seems like such a or is it did
he eat was he joking and it's hard to
tell in text you know yeah well yeah not
every Australian is sensible
I'm the article but I don't see anything
about him saying wasting human body is
there meat there's been a more than
several articles written on it maybe
someone extrapolated but the idea was he
was saying that people should eat meat
and if they want to eat meat they should
eat human because well maybe waste
animal rights activists might be just an
idiot ate your relatives yeah yeah but
just last thing wants people getting
that taste of people you know right no I
do do not need to go that
not yet
[Applause]